[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with christina patterson and sebastian
payne so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
the express leads with a warning from
so-called red bull conservative mps that
any tax rises and changes to the
pensions triple lock could lose the
party the next election
that's also the lead in the telegraph
with the headline tories at war over
idiotic tax increase
for its part the observer says labour
leader shakir starmer is under pressure
from his own party to back new taxes on
the rich to help fund social care
the sunday times reports that a senior
aide to prince charles has quit over
claims that he fixed an honor for a
saudi tycoon who donated more than 1.5
million pounds to royal charities the
prince's trust says it's investigating
that's also the lead in the mail on
sunday
the mirror says that many teenagers
wanting the kovid jab are facing long
trips of up to five hours because their
local area doesn't have a walk-in jab
center
while the people says that up to two
thousand children a day may be going
down with long covered
the star claims an exclusive from a
royal insider that princess diana's
romance with jodie fired before their
deaths in a car crash was in fact a
charade stage for the cameras
the sunday edition of the manchester
evening news shows former coronation
street actor sean ward being arrested at
an anti-vaccine protest in the city
and scotland on sunday has been
investigating the co2 emissions at the
venues for the cop 26 climate change
summit in november and says they have a
shocking energy efficiency record
and we're joined tonight by journalist
and author christina patterson and
whitehall editor for the financial times
sebastian payne welcome to you both
let's kick off straight away with the
telegraph and their headline their
tories at war over idiotic tax increase
as described it in that headline um
sebastian take us into this story
well this is over a plan to solve the uk
social care crisis that we're expecting
to come from boris johnson uh in the
coming weeks and it's been widely
trailed as these announcements often are
and the solution seems to be that he's
going to announce an increase to
national insurance between uh one and
two percent the final details haven't
been quite worked out but this is
important for two reasons number one um
it would be breaking conservative
manifesto um
pledge that said that national insurance
would not rise and second of all it's
generally a tax rise that conservative
mps don't like and it's the sunday
telegraph reports there's a huge amount
of unhappiness from people in the
cabinet in the government and on the
back benches about this saying this is
not the way to do it we should be
looking at making spending efficiencies
elsewhere to pay for the required monies
to deal with national insurance and i
think the fact is we've reached such a
stage that this is probably the only
answer for being honest here that the
coronavirus crisis has shown how damaged
the uk social care system is and how
disjointed it is the fact that it's not
hooked into primary care and mental
health care and all the other parts of
the nhs so there does need to be a
really radical overview and reform
that's going to require more money from
the state as well as more contributions
from the individuals and there's no idea
way to do this because boris johnson
wants to do it for the whole uk and with
income tax devolved in scotland there's
no way you can really do that so
national insurance is the only clear way
to raise those extra sums of money and
i'm sure the conservative mps won't be
very happy the question is how does the
public react do they say okay this is
something that we need to do or do they
say in fact this is boris johnson
breaking a very core electoral pledge
and we heard from his chief advisor
dominic cummings um on friday who said
that he would not be forgiven not by
this i'm not so sure i think
fundamentally people can see that our
health system needs reform that it is
disjointed and they will accept the need
for this um small tax increase which of
course she recall was done by gordon
brown in the early noughties and helped
repair the big gaps in the nhs at that
point yes and according to the article
the prime minister's insisting that that
it is vital to to save the nhs um he
will seek to justify the increase as
necessary to clear the backlog of
patients on hospital waiting lists after
official projections suggested the
number could reach 13 million so the
prime minister saying that it's
absolutely essential christina that
these rises take place
yes i i agree with sebastian that i
think people understand that the nhs
well actually i think the nhs is
probably the only area that and social
care probably the only two areas where
people would understand a tax rise
i think the problem is that our faith in
how the tories spend our money has been
severely eroded by
ppe cronyism and the way that so many
contracts
through the co through the pandemic have
been allocated to
friends essentially of tory mps and
i think many people understand that
social care has been something that has
been needed to be sorted out for many
years boris johnson claimed falsely one
of his many porcupies on the steps of
downing street that he had a plan for
social care obviously he didn't he's now
trying to kind of uh dust down
um the andrew uh the dildo report they
do not uh sort of the solution for
social care and do his version of it i
think the problem is this is going to
lead to an almighty battle between him
and rishi sunak and between those tory
mps who want a kind of small state and
wanted this vision of a kind of
buccaneering
brexit global britain that had low tax
small state and actually we're going in
precisely the opposite direction brexit
as we see is raising prices it's raising
the cost of labor and uh it's raising
taxes and obviously you know you have to
disentangle these things a bit but the
net result is that we have a tory
government that's very keen on tax rises
it's rising prices and very keen on
expenditure so from a tory point of view
that's not a great recipe for electoral
success yes and which moves us on to the
the sunday express and they're
suggesting that uh the tax rises could
cost the conservatives the next election
and this is speaking to uh conservative
mps sebastian
i just want to come back on a couple of
things that christina said there i think
first of all this question about pp and
contracting that's got absolutely
nothing to do with social care
whatsoever social care is about
provision from the nhs internally and
within local government as well now i
don't think you can really link those
two together and there obviously have
been questions to be asked about how
certain things were done in the pandemic
and of course it was a crisis and people
in whitehall had to make decisions at
the last moment but i don't think voter
concern about that which by the way
hasn't registered really at all in
opinion pose um is linked to that and i
think when boris johnson said he had a
plan his plan is the same plan that's
existed for a decade which is as
christina said is the deal not plan and
i think what the government's been
trying to do is through the covert
crisis manage this with the backlogs
with the expansions that need to be done
to the health service and there's
obviously there are finite resources
only so much you can do here on this
question of the express front page and
the red wall though and having just
finished writing a book about what the
red wall is and what happened the last
election and i'm not sure this is
actually a helpful or correct story at
all because my view is the red wall is
not that different from the rest of
england that these places they have very
distinct identities very distinct
cultural hinterland that tied them into
the labor movement but fundamentally
they're not some remote alien part of
the country that if this is unpopular um
for the west midlands to be unpopular
for the northeast of england that i
think you can't really segment it in
that particular way that i think this is
a really interesting ideological
question that we're going to see unfurl
over the next week though because ever
since the days of margaret thatcher
through john major to david cameron's
government the considers have been about
seeing the party of the small state of
lower tax they now seem to move beyond
that that's partly boris johnson
personally he likes to be liked he likes
to spend money wants big shiny projects
with his name on it's also the
circumstances of change we've got an
agent population that's part of the big
reason we need to do this social care
reform and i think the question is where
does labour go does labor support this
does it support different tax rises i'm
not quite sure which tax riser you could
do to get the scale of money required to
deal with the social care issue and if
they support it then what would they do
differently and that's the the difficult
one of the toys moving left was on
economics labor either has to agree with
it as they've done over the past two
years the pandemic go even further
leftwards now i'm not really too sure if
kiestama knows the answer of that and i
think it's on the observer front page
tomorrow the that dilemma is painted in
quite stark terms yes yes christina
agreeing with you the nod of the head or
on that um let's move on to the
telegraph and the health secretary um
proposing to make uh jabs a condition of
employment for nhs staff a good idea
christina considering that there are
shortages in in the health service
i think this is a very very difficult
question but on balance i think it
probably is a good idea i've just come
back from italy where they're now being
quite draconian but about uh you know
covered passports and mandatory
vaccination in the health service and in
all kinds of other areas as well you
can't get on a train you can't go in a
cafe you can't go to a restaurant you
can't get on a bus without having a
covered passport actually i think you're
getting a bus but most other things you
can't do without proof of a covert
passport or a negative test and i think
of course there are civil liberties
issues but
i think given that for example you know
we we've had mandatory vaccines in
schools in all kinds of uh in relation
to all kinds of diseases for a long time
i think it's just such a shame that it's
been so politicized in this country and
this whole kind of libertarian
um
instinct that has been pushed in
particular by tory back ventures which
is filtered down through lots of kind of
special interest groups it has polarized
people in a really unhelpful way we know
the vaccines are safe we know that it is
a moral duty to protect people in the
nhs obviously vaccines don't stop you
being infectious but they certainly help
and i do think if you're working in the
nhs it is irresponsible to go to work if
you're unvaccinated so i do support it
but i absolutely see that where there
are staff shortages this might create
problems and it already is in social
care where people are going off and
working for amazon and working for
supermarkets which is understandable
because pay is way too low yeah that has
been reported on christine sebastian for
the moment thank you
coming up as supermarkets struggle to
fill their shells what could we run out
of next
[Music]
sullivan tried to
kill me on two occasion occasions
afghanistan and pakistan
and all my life was in in
i had no life to well in
the time i was in afghanistan
but the last time when they hit me by
car they put me
to death and
i just decided to leave afghanistan
and
i came in the uk because the taliban not
except
women as a human being
and especially in uh
if the judges if they were female be a
church
they know accepting
female to be a judge
i'm not
very sure about that it's the taliban
strategy about islam
the islam island the islam i know
there is no problem to women be a church
because some different countries like
pakistan the others are some judges
family judges but everything the virgin
of islam of the taliban is a very scary
virgin
just for women especially for women
we need urgent help we need urgent help
if they come tomorrow it may be very
late taliban can come in in our home
in our place that we are hiding
in any time and can kill us
the taliban
said to the international media that we
forgive all the people it is it is a lie
they don't forget afghan woman
especially woman judge i'm asking the
government the policy makers the united
nations
um the people
in the uk and around the world uh to
think about afghanistan we are not the
safe place
um
i'm not i'm not the i'm i'm not the
position to go to help my field of
judges in afghanistan and women's rights
and other activists and people in
afghanistan they're the crisis there is
no food no safety i hope the united
nations
opened their eyes for afghanistan and
also the uk government
and
we really need support
[Music]
it was my vision to come and protect
english in future
[Music]
animals like lion can enter into bomas
they kill their livestocks and this
leads to human wildlife country
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me christina
patterson and sebastian payne let's have
a look at these sunday times and this
story about an aide to uh prince charles
that has has quit over an honor being
given to um a saudi tycoon sebastian
tell us a bit more
so this is a chap called uh michael
fawcett who is the princess former valet
and he stepped down as the chief
executive of the princess foundation
this is after the sunday times have
revealed some quite surprising things
that um he fixed an honor for a sally
tycoon who had given more than 1.5
million pounds to the prince's charities
and this goes back to a lot of reporting
that we've done at the ft and the sunday
times have done as well about cash for
access um involving the future king that
there's been people who have been you
know um involved with his charities and
also in some cases involved with the
conservative party and giving donors to
that who have essentially you know got
certain access got certain favors in
return for doing that and this one is a
particularly serious one because
obviously knight hoods are something
that are done by the government but also
the palace has a role into that too and
i think there's been a concern from
quite quite sometimes people in white
hall but also people who know and
the royal family quite well about
how this is working because prince
charles has a whole network of
organizations and charities that all
support his interests and do an awful
lot of good work we should of course say
but what is the clarity over who is
doing what here and this salary tycoon
gave 1.5 million pounds very sizable sum
of money there on what basis was that
done was this formal was this informal
when was it revealed you know it
shouldn't be the job of us in the media
for this stuff to be in the public
domain so although this is a
particularly shocking example it does
sometimes wonder if there may be a lot
more to come and when we first wrote
about this sort of thing in the ft a
couple of months ago saw him seen
inevitable and just to say a spokesman
for the prince's foundation has said
that the foundation takes very seriously
allegations that have recently been
brought to its attention and the matter
is currently under investigation uh
let's go to the daily star next not
something we often uh do on the press
preview um but it's talking about what
we are running out of uh the latest
thing pickles
does that upset you christina
not personally but
but uh i think we might be looking at
well we're actually to be honest already
looking at rather odd eventually shelves
and i uh there are sort of endless
reports every day about how many empty
shells will be looking at by christmas
and how if you want your child to get a
toy for christmas you better snap one up
now uh more seriously we can't get flu
vaccines at the moment because of the
shortage of haulers so um
i mean again it comes back to brexit
pushing wages up which one could argue
was a good thing i think uh many lorry
drivers are now being paid more than 50
grand which uh you know is a very very
good wage and i think some of us might
be rushing to apply to be a lorry driver
but clearly not enough people are at the
moment because there are these shortages
and compounded of course by the red tape
that we were told we would lose and have
in fact gained as a result of brexit